it's either jail or treatment doesn't
make any sense when the vast majority of
people don't need either this book is a
hybrid if you will
memoir science book and policy what I
thought I'd do here today was the focus
a little bit on the science why I wrote
the book
I've been studying drugs for about 2223
years and one of the things that I
contend in the book is that there have
been some assumptions made about drugs
that are false bad and that has led to
bad drug policy and so I think I'll talk
about one component of what I highlight
in the book and that component what I'd
like to talk about is the work or the
science that I've been doing and other
people have been doing with
methamphetamine back in 2005 I got a
call from the Office of National Drug
Control Policy asking me to participate
in a roundtable of writers who were
interested in writing stories about
methamphetamine they wanted their
stories to be more realistic they were
writers for things like Law & Order CSI
magazines and so forth at this round
table we had participated the panelists
were a us assistant attorney and
undercover narcotics officer an adult
person who was addicted to
methamphetamine an adolescent who was
addicted to methamphetamine and myself
my role at the panel was to help
participants understand where the
science was at a time what we knew from
the empirical information and so I
proceeded to summarize what we knew
basically what I said was that we had at
the up to that point we had tested
relatively low oral doses in the
laboratory where we gave to people and
we evaluated the effects of those doses
of methamphetamine on cognitive
performance mood heart rate blood
pressure those sorts of things
and my conclusions were that the drug
was quite unremarkable in fact when
people who are well-rested you didn't
see much in terms of cognitive
disruptions you didn't see any those
those low doses produce some euphoria
but moderate range of euphoria when I
finished my presentation my fellow
panelists were horrified they were
horrified because they had told stories
about the horrors of methamphetamine
that they saw in the natural ecology
they recounted stories of
methamphetamine users developing
superhuman strength when someone was on
methamphetamine it was said that you had
to increase the calibre a weapon regular
tasers no longer worked with these these
individuals another story that was
recounted was that methamphetamine was
like no other drug that law enforcement
had ever seen this particular cop said
he had more than 20-some years of
experience on the force and had never
seen anything like methamphetamine and
he had seen crack users and that sort of
thing so there's drug methamphetamine he
claimed were exerted unique
pharmacological effects finally when I
challenged some the claims that were
being made he turned to me and he said
dr. Hart when you see a parent cut the
head of their child off and throw it at
you didn't maybe perhaps you become a
believer so the idea was that this
parent was so cognitively impaired
she cut the head off of her kid and
threw it at this cop now I tried to
explain that these types of stories
these anecdotes particularly about drugs
they weren't new we had heard them
before the stories about drug users
developing superhuman strength the
stories about some new drug being like
no other drug we
ever seen and the stories about drugs
causing this sort of this wide range of
cognitive disruptions what I like to do
here in the next few minutes is just
evaluate or look at these three sort of
claims that seem to be pervasive in our
history when it comes to drugs the first
these individuals developing superhuman
strength at this roundtable I tried to
explain that this wasn't new if you go
back to the New York Times for example
if everywhere 8th 1914 what you find
there is a huge editorial Negro cocaine
fiends our new southern menace in this
PC argued that black people when they
have cocaine they develop superhuman
strength so much so that southern police
forces had to increase the caliber of
their weapons they moved from the 32
caliber weapon to the 38 caliber weapon
because the 32 caliber weapons or
bullets didn't affect black people on
cocaine I know it sounds comical but
this was actually believed and these
things come back in new forms if you all
think about maybe a year and a half ago
two years ago we heard about the guy in
Miami who chewed the face off of another
guy the officer believes the man clearly
clearly was on some very very powerful
drugs it was said that the person was on
bath salts and bath salts caused such
extreme effects that you get discount of
behavior but when the toxicology was in
we looked at what was in a person's
system there was no bath salts in this
person system the only thing that was in
the person system was THC and THC we
don't know when was the last time this
person that used THC it could have been
two weeks but the point is is that these
arguments these claims they are recycled
generation after generations and we
laugh at some of them because of the
language but the language is tempered
for to fit the contemporary folk
where it doesn't seem so outrageous if
you're not a critical thinking but but
of course most of these claims are just
exaggerations the other claim that
methamphetamine produces unique
cognitive effects or unique effects in
general I hadn't collected any evidence
to address this claim but what I did
along with my PhD student at the time
Matt Kirkpatrick we ran a study in which
we gave research participants of course
we passed all of the ethical
requirements we gave research
participants intranasal methamphetamine
at a low dose and a large dose on one
day but it's all under blind conditions
and we gave them diem fetta mean two
active ingredient in adderall on other
days and we evaluated the effects of
these drugs of course posse bo was
included we evaluated the effects of
these drugs to see whether or not the
methamphetamine was unique compared to
just regular and fetta me because when
you look at the chemical structure of
these drugs they look almost identical
excepting for the methyl group that's on
the methamphetamine structure but they
are nearly identical and what we found
was that drugs produced nearly identical
effects they are the same drug
methamphetamine is the same drug as the
active ingredient in adderall and so the
notion that methamphetamine produces
unique effect it's just simply not
supported by evidence from research we
weren't the first people to do that
other folks had done this sort of thing
with oral methamphetamine compared to
oral D and feta me finally I was
interested in this notion that
methamphetamine causes all of these
cognitive disruptions if you all have
been paying attention in the country for
the past Oh five to ten years you might
know something about them Montana Meth
project in which they make these slick
advertisement which they call education
about methamphetamines that or the
dangers of methamphetamines and
oftentimes these advertisements indicate
that methamphetamine causes widespread
cognitive disruptions and then it seemed
as though the scientific literature was
in support of what was being said in
these advertisements so what I did in
2012 I published a review of all of the
scientific literature that was relevant
for cognitive performance and for brain
imaging what I concluded was this the
scientific interpretation or the
interpretations in the scientific
literature were wildly overstated in
terms of the effects of methamphetamine
on cognition in terms of the effects of
methamphetamine on brain structure now I
wish I was the first person to do this
sort of thing to really call into
question to exaggerations but since we
are here at reason I have to give props
to Jacob solemn Jacob have been writing
about this for some period the vast
majority of people who use illegal drugs
are not addicts are not heavy users and
they're not posing any kind of threat to
other people nor nor are they harming
themselves that's well that's your
opinion I don't know if this is just
opinion this is based upon data
well that's available from the federal
government if you look at patterns of
abuse you'll see in any you can submit
of data any way you want is quite plain
mr. song this is a discussion all right
don't get in a car and don't come near
my family if you want to see a
scientific paper on this my paper was
published in neuropsychopharmacology in
2012 and you can actually see it for
yourself so given that we have
assumptions our drug policy is based on
these faulty assumptions one of the
things that I call for in high price is
that we should rethink we evaluate how
we are regulating drugs like
methamphetamine drugs like heroin drugs
like cocaine and so forth and the main
reason I call for this reevaluation is
this each year in this country we arrest
1.5 million people for drug-related
violations
more than 80% of them are for simple
possession now if our assumptions that
these that these drugs are so dangerous
we have to go after them with such
ferocity our faulty I think that we
could decrease the blemishes that we put
on people's records by decriminalizing
drugs rather than the approach that
we're taking now when you call for
decriminalization in this country you
have to provide some education because
the country is quite ignorant about drug
policy about drugs in general
decriminalization is not legalization
legalization is what we're doing what
alcohol alcohol you're 21 or older you
can purchase alcohol without fear of
being prosecuted you can sell alcohol
legally decriminalization you cannot
sell drugs they still remain illegal
possession also remains illegal but you
can no longer get a criminal record from
possession a drug instead it would be
treated like we treat traffic violations
that way we decrease the likelihood of
putting blemishes on people's records
and enhance the likelihood that they
will be able to get jobs and contribute
to society when we think about the guys
who have occupied the White House
President Obama President Bush President
Clinton all three of those guys used
illegal drugs in their youth if they
would have been caught they would have
been they would have gotten felony
charges and probably not probably would
not have been allowed to make the
contributions that they have made to our
country my expertise are the
of drugs on people right and there's a
and wonder the things that happens in
this discussion is that experts are very
comfortable talking on areas in which
they have limited expertise I'm not one
of them and I have limited expertise in
markets but what I can tell you is why I
favor decriminalization rather than
legalization legalization for example
would make drugs probably more available
I don't know that to be that's a
prediction for some but what I do know
is that legalization will provide the
opportunity for people to exaggerate the
extent of the harms caused by drugs I
know that for a fact
and because the country is so ignorant
about what drugs actually do I am
arguing in high price that we should
decriminalize and then have a
corresponding increase in education
about these drugs realistic education so
when I say realistic education since
I've been talking about methamphetamine
methamphetamines since it causes people
to have to have increased heart rate
blood pressure and so forth number one
killer in the United States is heart
disease if you have cardiac issues the
public health message will be blared
don't take methamphetamine
another issue methamphetamine is
outstanding at keeping people away
chronic sleep loss associated with
cancers all kinds of cancers associated
with psychiatric illness the public
health message would be please don't
take methamphetamine near bedtime get
sleep those sorts of things this is
realistic education to help people so
that's why my focus has been on
decriminalization rather than
legalization I think the country is too
ignorant we haven't had an adult
conversation about drugs and I'm trying
to do that what high price
yes stories just totally fabricated on
thin air because I recall way back when
it was demon weed about marijuana and
devil rum and they all just seem to be
fabrications now one thing I don't I
don't want to leave the audience with
the oppression that psychoactive drugs
the ones that we're talking about I
don't want to leave you with the
impression that they don't have
potentially powerful mind-altering
effects because they do now many of the
stories told about those drugs like
marijuana in the 1930s the demon rum and
that sort of thing
drugs serve as a convenient tool stories
about drugs serve as convenient tools to
further demonize groups that we don't
like so we associate marijuana with
those Mexicans who are taking jobs from
the good folks in Texas from those four
they're taking jobs from from white
folks in the south black folks are
taking jobs from white folks in the
south we don't like them so we associate
drugs that are not used widely in the
society with a specific despised group
now today it's a hell of a lot more
difficult to demonize marijuana as we
once did in the 1930s the use of
marijuana at that time was not as
widespread as it is today and so when
you have something like fast-forward to
the 1980s a number of people had used
powder cocaine we're in LA here
Hollywood was really supporting that
industry but there was not a number of
people using crack cocaine so now you
can say this is a new form of cocaine
it's not the cocaine that you're using
my man this is a new form and so and
it's associated with these people even
no black people didn't use crack cocaine
at high race and white folks but
certainly based on the media sort of
betrayal depiction it was easy to get
that impression and so you can now
vilify crack cocaine methamphetamine
today it's associated with despise
groups poor white trash of
gay folks that sort of thing you can and
a lot a smaller number a relatively
small number of people use
methamphetamine so you can vilify those
groups but it's a hell of a lot more
difficult to vilify marijuana today the
vast majority of people who use these
substances are not addicted maybe Tim to
20 percent are but 80 90 percent or not
most of our attention when we talk about
these drugs are focused on this small
pathological group and so when you read
something like high price I focused more
on the eighty to ninety percent so
decriminalization in terms of its impact
on addiction treatment well I hope that
we would redistribute the money that law
enforcement currently gets for we spent
twenty six billion dollars a year on our
sort of dealing with this drug problem
if we redistribute the money into
treatment treatment research it would
enhance treatment we currently have some
pretty good treatments to treat
substance abuse it's just that we also
have a lot of quacks out there and we
have to we also have to realize too that
like law enforcement the treatment
industry has a stake in our current
approach so it's either jail or
treatment doesn't make any sense when
the vast majority of people don't need
either I sit on a number
review committees and one of the things
that we want to make sure before people
get approval to study these drugs is
that they have the appropriate amount of
experience to do this research make sure
that they have the appropriate
safeguards in place because you can
imagine if you have people do this kind
of research and they don't have the
experience they don't have the
appropriate safeguards and someone gets
hurt
you can imagine how that will set back
to scientific investigation into this
study think about timothy leary him and
his antics set back the research into
hallucinogens forty years and so we
don't want to see that happen again and
so if people want to study these drugs
and they have the appropriate training
experience facilities I'm willing to
help anybody if they have those sort of
things in place is there any study
that's ever shown any of these
substances force people to do bad things
violence crimes and so on we have been
doing this research for decades in which
we bring people into the lab and
administer drugs to in order to develop
better treatments in order to determine
the effects of drugs on people for a
wide range of reasons in none of these
cases
I mean we've given drugs like heroin
methamphetamine crack cocaine marijuana
you name it alcohol so we've given
thousands of doses of these drugs
haven't seen any violence in the context
in which we give these drugs that's not
to say that people who use drugs don't
get violence sometimes it has to be
within the context so yeah you might see
some violence with what some of these
drugs but it's certainly not because of
the pharmacology of the drugs so people
sometimes when we have this kind of
discussion we sometimes think that well
if one person gets violent on crack
cocaine and we were more lenient with
our policies that's enough to change the
policy of course that's ridiculous
you know the notion
we can prevent every accident every sort
of bad thing from happening in a society
if people have that notion they probably
shouldn't be allowed to talk to the
public